a fetus is literally a parasite like it
is sucking the life from a mother yeah
every single day what happens not a
mother I'm guessing okay latest
installment have changed my mind is
actually kind of a sequel we're
revisiting the topic of abortion I'm
pro-life change my mind the first one
was an hour long with one person
some people said they'd like to see more
of a mix so this was an SMU it was part
of a five-hour changed my mind marathon
and you get to see what happens with
three different people what one person
is actually returned visit some people
change their minds some people at least
rationalize their positions and we kind
of find some middle ground and then some
people are just confrontational no
matter what hope this helps you Pablo
nice to meet you Pablo do you want to
hold a microphone sure okay please hold
like below your mouth out here okay good
that became a point of contention
earlier and I don't want to freed not be
heard so I am pro-life and I am willing
to hear the other side's argument have
my mind change basically I'm pro-choice
more because of personal liberty you
know okay I think that if in an instance
where I don't know a woman is raped and
sure she is she gets pregnant I think
that she should have the right to abort
baby why I wanna have why because um I
think number one it's your body mm-hmm
it's for life and
you know without her there wouldn't be a
baby in the first place so I think
that's why you know what if it's not her
body
what if she's aborting another body
well then that would be murder
it would you know it really comes down
to at what point is it another body yes
well you also use the word life said
it's her body it's her life
so obviously the big disagreement I'm
pro-life I couldn't care less what a
woman does with her body right they can
get the god-awful
eyebrow tattoo that leaves them a scar
for 50 years after that it's their
prerogative but when it's another body
inside of your body when it's another
life that's a violation of course of the
non-aggression principle so that is the
only question that really needs to be
answered right if we're gonna find
common ground yeah are you just keep on
you cuz I've got a mic on me so you know
I appreciate it though you're playing
reporter for me Hannah
Pablo Channel 5 News you know there's a
there's a certain point where okay it's
it is somebody else's body and not I
mean okay it really comes down to at
what point
a woman is gonna abort you know if she's
gonna abort you know eight months you
know pregnant and I think that right
there from I agree with you see because
um I think that that's closer to being
an actual human being you know another
person okay you know when it's three
weeks and it's I'm cell or a little
membrane or whatever I mean I don't know
about biology but I mean when it's not
an actual body okay I when it doesn't
have legs you know it doesn't have
actual fingers I you know I think that
at that point she can I can ask you a
couple questions
yeah it's great like so you can keep the
microphone yeah we'll hear me you said
maybe eight months maybe not three weeks
right you said I don't know I don't know
a whole lot about biology yeah but you
agree that if it is a life you know the
right to take that life yeah okay so we
agree that you don't have the right to
take another life and you've conceded
that you're not a biologist so you don't
know the exact the exact sort of
prenatal developmental stages right I
don't there are people who do okay okay
so but I'm just a for our conversation
here I'm not either
okay so let me ask you this we're gonna
do kind of go through the philosophical
idea first then we can get to the
medical let's say your
tonight driving home from school and you
see someone in the road and you're about
to hit them but you have enough time to
stop would you stop yeah why because I
don't want to show somebody okay exactly
okay no that's a good answer if not we'd
have to have you written up let's take
that same scenario you're driving home
tonight and use some you see someone
walk out in front of the car you're not
entirely positive but you're pretty sure
that could be a person and you do have
the ability to stop do you stop your
question no it's not so it's not a
person no no it you're you're pretty
sure it's a person but it's a little
fast and blurry you have enough time to
stop you're not sure that it's a person
but you think it's a person do you stop
yeah I would stop for anything okay why
because I don't want to hurt my car
Oh for is because your car well that's
fair I see a branch and I try to evade
it so you they can just use you and IKEA
at Planned Parenthood and job done so
you would stop right you're saying
because why I wasn't your car you
wouldn't wanna hurt ya a human being
killed whatever it is you know okay even
if it's a dog or something okay so even
in the second instance where you weren't
sure you erred on the side of life yeah
you erred in the side of not killing so
in this case where you've conceded you
don't know where life begins you don't
know if it's a life or not shouldn't we
err on the side of life and not
terminating life yeah we we should and
on that side I do agree with you but I
believe that you know again I think it's
more about personal liberty and you know
when it comes down to a woman's body I
think that a woman should have the right
we're talking on another body right we
owe both both the great woman can do
anything this is this is the issue a
woman can do anything she wants with her
own body
yeah if a woman wants to amputate
herself and a doctor says I'll do it and
this actually occurs now these people
identify as Fu T's this is a common
practice I'm fine with it
right so we need to frame in the
argument fairly and accurately
no one who's pro-life is telling a woman
what to do with their body in any other
instance outside of when it directly
ends the life of another person
so it's the burden of proof is on you
why is it not a life well I mean I want
to say it's not a life but I also you
know would say it's an actual human
being like that I mean I'm not really
for you know actually can yeah the other
stage where you know it's an actual baby
but when you know like I said well if
it's so sell or whatever I mean I so
when is it okay
I would say three weeks probably one
month two months three months at the
point where three months actually little
toes that's when okay probably so before
we get to that because that's medical
what makes a human what what makes a
human being what is a human being a
brain a brain is human being yeah like
once this has a basically a formed brain
at that point I believe it's wrong -
okay baby but so before that what
defines a formed brain we just threw out
brain very definitively so what
determines a brain you mean a [ __ ] you
mean a functioning brain cerebral
capabilities yeah or I mean just the
actual membrane the actual you know pink
stuff you know when once a they start
forming that or have it that at that
point I believe
well that's forming immediately because
the tissue forms into a multitude of
ways right so the young you would have
to say as soon as conception a zygote at
that point because it could be
potentially brain tissue yeah so that
doesn't really hold up to scrutiny
so you're saying brain so it would have
to be a developed brain at that point
otherwise you wouldn't be able to
differentiate between tissues so it
develops brain this would assume
cognitive abilities
yeah okay I mean obvious isn't my
argument but it's very common it goes
back it goes back hundreds of years but
bench peers use it what if I'm in a coma
I'm brain dead what if my brain doesn't
function that made me less of a person
is that less of a life can you kill me
mm-hmm
not necessarily I mean I wouldn't you
know kill you you know but you know
seems like you might want to with your
car
as long as someone waxes it afterward
okay but honestly you know at that point
that certain situation would not be okay
because um you know at one point it was
life and there is still hope that he can
wake up one day from the coma ah so now
we're dealing with the potential of life
yeah you see all that short you know
where this goes right yeah so you said
brain you said well not really brain a
functioning brain because even if it's a
non functioning brain it matters there's
the potential of it being a functioning
brain so now we're back to square one
that would of course apply to the baby
growing in the womb it's a life by your
definition why do you have the right to
kill well I'm not you a woman yeah I
would say um a woman has a right because
you know it basically comes down to it
being her body you know it doesn't it
doesn't you just said that it was
another body but another life inside
your body if someone or somebody were
inside my body that I do not want inside
I think I should have the right to get
him out so every time you're having sex
with a woman or man they have the right
to kill you because you're inside their
body okay yeah yeah they actually would
have the right anyone of the right to
kill you or to get me out I mean if she
doesn't want me inside her body I think
she should have the right to get you out
if the woman I'm not saying you're let's
get beyond you're not raping the person
okay okay all right Pablo I don't think
you're a rapist I think you're a little
little bit shifty with the microphone
but far from a rapist
if you're having sex with someone you
are in their body male or female you
don't need to tell me I don't care
that's not the point of this
conversation do they have the right so
we do they have the right to kill you
yes and no no if they don't have their
know they don't have the right if it's
consensual but if it's okay so let's use
that because well that's the only one
that's relevant right because this is a
baby this baby did not consent to being
harmed but the woman did not consent to
being raped either
okay let's let's use this let's remove
rape from the table let's deal with
ninety-nine point more than 99 percent
of abortions right okay so let's say
rape incest let's take it off the table
all right so then you would say that the
vast majority of abortions based on your
standard of what is a life that people
who abort when they are not raped when
it is not non-consensual that that is
morally wrong yeah yeah in there and
there I completely agree with you okay I
would have to say I'm more pro-choice
just because of that sense well so
you're more for just because of one
percent less than one percent but you're
pro-life so you don't think a woman
should be able to abort if it was a
consensual sexual engagement that
resulted in a pregnancy you don't think
abortion is a is a I do not think it's
okay because I think there are a lot of
people that abuse the fact that they can
abort and that's the vast majority of
abortions yeah and I'm actually against
that but okay just because of that
certain situation of those the people
being raped for that reason I would have
to subside to so because of a very very
small percentage of people rather than
allow other choices could you say you're
pro-choice I'm pro-choice too you know
yeah I'm Pro for choices right mm-hmm
abstinence adoption pregnancy
contraception I'm just not procuring
right there's a fifth choice so you're
saying I'm Pro killing if there's rape
involved and if you want to remove the
extreme examples and say that you're
pro-life and all other examples that's
fine that's not the policy of the
platform right now that's pro-abortion
and I respect that you would disagree
with many of the people here who
consider themselves pro-choice but
that's a that that's an extreme example
yeah so you know in that case I would
say no
forcing a woman to carry a baby in that
case I'm simply precluding someone from
killing a baby but again we're dealing
with less than 1% of abortion so we
agree on 99 point something percent of
abortions that it's morally incorrect to
end a life okay one person honey because
one percent of a billion is still 100
Millions
I know but the 99 percent is hundreds of
millions of babies that have been
aborted ten million of it but yeah but
what about the hundreds of millions of
babies you've admitted their lives that
have just been ended and yeah and I
agree with you I I wouldn't I say that
I'm saying that's morally okay all right
well thank you finally I appreciate it I
Priya taking them Thank You Man right
great conversation thank you very much
Pablo I appreciate it yeah I can hold it
if you'd rather me hold it okay what's
your name
it's Syd Syd yeah nice to meet you said
Stephen all right I'm pro-life yeah you
can change my mind I heard or you read
you were on campus
yeah I am able to read you're at a very
good campus I would hope so yeah I know
I mean I'm pretty much I'm first of all
it's not through abortion as pro-choice
really yeah why is that because it's the
option to have an abortion or to not
that's what choice is about so there's
an element I guess a pro-life isn't it
necessarily and pro-choice because you
have the option okay yeah so are you
pro-choice when it comes to what amount
of taxes you pay or I pay excuse me you
say pro-choice I'll get to it
philosophically said you're pro-choice
it's only about choice would you
consider yourself very consistently an
advocate of choice and liberty sure okay
she would be pro-choice where I could
choose what taxes I pay so would you be
pro-choice and I can determine what laws
I obey I know I know you laugh but we'll
get to in a second okay
because it's not your choice if it's
terminating another life so it is it
does come down to abortion because
here's the thing pro-choice would apply
to everything else
taxes driving SUVs carbon credits policy
we're discussing the issue of abortion
right yes because I think we would all
have differing opinions on choices
regarding other issues in this case
we're just talking about abortion are we
pro-abortion Pro right to abort or
pro-life right support yes okay Pro
right Pro right to abort okay good so
let's use that to pro right to abort you
can throw it virtually you can use
pro-choice that's fine I won't
okay change my mind well this is the
purpose you sat down here I'm pro-life
so where it where am I wrong where are
you wrong I mean okay well going back to
the what you're talking about earlier
with the other person I think there's
missing an important part of the
argument whenever I think his name is
Pablo Pablo was saying that you like the
coma yeah I guess so I knew can you go
for that again sleeping why was you only
bringing that argument cuz he was
talking about defining life yeah so I
think the only argument that really
matters is the funny I find life that's
my question
yeah that's the basis of those yes yes
let me let me try and be as clear as
possible I don't want to I don't want to
wiggle on this or do you feel that I've
tricked anyone I believe life begins at
conception because I believe it's the
only consistent line to draw that's
where a unique genetic code human DNA no
I'm fine I'm Pro birth control birth
control African yeah let me explain you
why because preventing conception is
different than aborting after conception
is it yeah it is that's when the light
starts that you're purposely preventing
the conception from happening is that
not aborting no it's not because every
time I masturbated I'd be committing
mass genocide
no see what you're doing is you're
taking a very clear answer
no but I'm twisting it to try and make
it nuanced I believe it believe I
believe it begins at conception real
life within everyone's genital organs
right now there is a life within every
single one's genital organs do you mean
a separate life within your organs and
my organs so let me ask you tell me your
genitals right so you mean a different
life from yours I mean your this is a
life I'm a life it goes on you're
dependent yes personally I don't believe
life starts until outside of the womb
okay so really okay so I do believe life
begins at conception you believe life
exclusively begins outside of the womb
correct okay so is it your
presupposition that abortion up until
the moment it leaves the birth canal is
acceptable sure not nine months sure
eight months sure you can blow that to
life no okay you haven't changed my mind
thank you very much yeah we're not gonna
find common ground if you're okay with
the boarding a fully fully sentient
fully viable baby at nine months
yeah that's just not true I appreciate
it you haven't changed my mind I mean if
you had a difference but yeah it is with
nine months if you're okay aborting up
to nine months I don't think were gonna
find common ground but I appreciate it
SID thank you
marce Marcella yes thank you so much my
name is Steven Steven I am pro-life and
I am willing to hear the other side they
should willing to have my mind changed
by convincing arguable Eve that the
fundamental of this topic is rooted
where life begins and it's not a battery
whether to abort or to not abort a
living life it's the discussion is on
where the living life begins okay just
to start off though I am actually a
practicing Catholic so I myself my
religious views are pro-life but my
religious views don't always coincide
with my political views and the rights
that the Constitution grant grants us if
it makes me you don't to look at the
crowd you can yeah it's it's more
conversational it's usually doesn't
happen usually just everyone wants to
hurt me yeah you just look at me that's
fine I don't I I appreciate you'd take
some take some guts to do that I know
more people are afraid of speaking in
front of public than dying yeah so when
you stand up comedy sometimes both
happen I know I believe that not I don't
believe in pro-choice I believe in the
right to abort when it is those extreme
cases okay since it is such a small
percent of the population you said those
99 percent yeah isn't it yeah but as a
woman I don't know what it's like to be
raped sure and I don't know what it's
like to have something in my body that I
feel like it's not mine sure so I
believe that it's not my right to tell
that woman
if that she has to have something in her
body that's dependent on her to survive
right I it's been argued that I believe
that a baby is a person so much so that
if you kill a pregnant woman is that I I
don't know if this is actually the law
can actually kind of the double marry
law counts as a double murder so
religiously I believe that if you kill a
pregnant woman most likely she wanted
that baby you're killing you're
stripping her of that life that she was
nurturing and fostering but there are
certain points where before the fetus
will actually feel the pain and will
actually can I ask you a question
because you said you were pro-life
except for the extreme instances of rape
yes but now it sounds like you're saying
maybe you're okay with abortion before
pain I just want to make sure I don't
because I believe that you're not when
you get raped you know you got raped so
like we're getting away from rape now
your toe or you mean just just if the
baby can experience pain in the sense of
a rape sorry I'm working up to it okay
sorry I just want to make sure it yeah
I'll clear it
I'll clear it up but like built the way
you build up like that's okay go ahead
like go ahead my brain is working right
now so when you get raped
you know you've been raped so I as
difficult as that situation is I believe
that it is your responsibility as a
person to go in and get yourself checked
out because there is a possibility you
might be pregnant and it's your
responsibility to do that before a baby
inside of you develops that could
potentially feel the pain of an abortion
so even in the instance of rape you're
saying only an abortion before the
ability for baby to feel pain yes okay
and that's where I believe okay trailer
boys and outside of rape you don't think
it's okay at all yeah okay that's what I
wanted to clarify
morally and ethically believe and that
there are other options and you
consented in having that responsibility
placed upon you like middle school you
learn when you have sex you get a baby
like it's more than likely so if you're
gonna have sex you know what your
consequences are and unless you were
forced to do it
yeah I think that you should own up to
your response but your actions I think
that's great I think that there can be a
lot of research medical research done to
find out the most humane way to do it
because they're very polarized opinions
and there is a compromise the compromise
isn't going to make everybody a hundred
percent happy but compromises are
usually what's fair okay there's a lot
to unpack there so I appreciate you
giving me your whole point of view do
you consider yourself liberal
conservative Republican believe in that
okay well it's important finding myself
what devote I haven't turned like I
turned eighteen after I could vote okay
do you plan to vote yes okay so let's
get rid of that kind of this whole idea
this whole post modernist I don't like
any labels because you're gonna vote
right so it matters what platform you're
voting for
I believe it matters what candidate I'm
okay well the platform the DNC and for
example Hillary Clinton Bernie Sanders
it's abortion taxpayer-funded on-demand
period yes it's not about rape yes it's
not even mentioned so it so it's
important to know where you line up and
we're going to vote because that is the
platform that's the legislation we're
talking about right so I want to hear
your opinion yes well and that's why I'm
pro-life because I understand that
people try to frame the argument as a
let's take standpoint and a religious
you know I just I'm anti killing
that's not smart that's just my actual
position and it seems that you are too
because you've said you believe it's a
financial point so that's the only
reason Oh with you that's because that's
the platform of the DNC let's let's
remove that let's remove the financial
standpoint I believe it was Sid who just
said she's ok with abortion up to nine
months well this is the DNC platform you
see it was considered a travesty of
human justice in Texas where they said
you can't have an abortion after it was
it I think was twenty two weeks or
twenty weeks 20 weeks okay so that's
considered the platform that people
would be voting for and it seems to me
that you would be very much against
killing a baby at 20 weeks yes so that's
why I say it's important because we're
not just discussing extreme examples
when we're discussing abortion the idea
of pro-life or prohibition we are
discussing policy and we are discussing
as a society whether we are
fundamentally a society of life or a
life of death on that point yes go ahead
then I was gonna build to what you're
coming but yeah what well I'm proposing
is that we put something new on the
table where instead of picking we try to
reform yeah okay and I would be the
taxpayers dollars would be severely
stripped down if 99% of the cases are
also stripped down yeah how about no
taxpayer paying for any abortions oh
okay well you find common ground there
see I'm trying to find I'm trying to
find comment down here so we find common
ground there that's important I don't I
don't actually have a stance on that yet
because I I'm not educated enough okay
so so don't pay my like you gonna pay
taxes most people here in school don't
know like I I paid them for you I feel
like I'm not really entitled to an
opinion if it's not coming out of my
paycheck that's well $50 they can guess
what make you're gonna be a conservative
I can tell that a lot of people change
if any once you start paying taxes and
when you start paying taxes for example
think of something think of something
that really bothers you just tell me
something that really bothers you
hypocrisy
okay well hypocrisy is a cop tell me an
action that really bothers you
like when people
but like oh I don't know okay let's take
a critical imagine this imagine that you
start paying taxes and you have people
who are running for president saying
actionable hypocrisy taxpayer-funded on
demand period and they pay for a
platform for someone espoused
hypocritical views and your taxes are
paying for it right you want to sound
stupid but I really didn't understand
the point is when you're paying taxes
and any taxpayer dollars are going to
organizations that fund abortions or is
where I'm from in Quebec entire almost
entirely subsidize abortions it's really
important to define what life is right
because tax dollars aren't going just to
abortions in perhaps 1% of rate right
they're going to killing tens of
millions of lives tens of millions of
innocent lives outside of rape I
understand that but if we reform yes I
understand what I'm saying but that's
not even a proposal right now
so right now our options are abortion
basically as we know it on demand or
some kind of reform in which case yeah
we'd vote Republican but why settle on
picking an option when we can put a new
one on the table I would be I would be
open to putting anyone on the tables so
maybe we should just change the card
change the card no but I'm not that
would be unprovided doesn't change I'm
pro-life but I'm saying if it would save
tens of millions of babies I would be
willing to put up no taxpayer-funded
abortions at least as baby steps but is
it
ideologically is it into intellect thank
you is it intellectually is it
philosophically consistent if you say
you believe it to life but then in the
case of of rape support abortion okay
babies like I'm like 18 I need to figure
that out I know that's I'm trying to
figure it out try to match my like
religious views with my sure political
and freedom views but I'm that's not my
situation so where I found peace and
comfort with my decision is to restrict
it and take that first step and then a
pre approach the conversation okay so
let's reappropriation the rape idea like
I said I was willing to concede that
territory but that's what you came in to
talk about are you've said it to life
that's why you're pro-life in other
cases yes is the life of a baby as a
result of
rape inherently less valuable than one
that isn't I I personally don't believe
so but there are millions of people that
would argue that it's not a life yet so
if there are millions of people who
believe slavery is ok it doesn't mean
it's okay right yeah so I don't think
I'm saying is let's not appeal to the
masses if you believe it to life it
doesn't matter if someone says it isn't
right mm-hmm it's kind of like Rachel
Dolezal I can tell you I'm black until
I'm blue in the face doesn't make me a
black man right you can people can say
well because of rape I don't think it's
a life all they want that doesn't change
the nature of humanity right and you've
already agreed that it is a life so then
that question becomes philosophic but
really didn't or philosophy now is the
life of the the baby as a byproduct of
rape less value but something you're not
considering because the harm that it
could be causing to the mother but what
about the baby if we're talking about a
life nothing is more harmful than murder
okay but also when then that's kind of
also bringing in the question of the
death penalty because when you're or
like being put in prison when you harm
someone you get consequences and I'm but
I don't I don't think so I don't think
so um and here's my point I understand
that there's less than 1% of abortions
that are and my wife works at a crisis
pregnancy center right so she actually
helps women by the way Planned
Parenthood doesn't have the services for
people who are out there if you're
looking to actually get assistance
mammograms or child care services if you
want to consider adoption they don't
even have that ability so she works at a
crisis pregnancy center that provides
all of those things she actively tries
to help people she's pro-choice she's
Pro again contraception she's Pro
abstinence
she's Pro have a baby or pro adoption
there are four choices there and so my
promise framing in an argument as though
it's pro-choice or anti choice for the
woman even in that instance okay and
I've already conceded the territory but
let's go into the philosophy of it I am
NOT at any point forcing a woman I would
never propose forcing a woman to carry a
child I would never propose a woman but
to force a woman forcibly make that
woman carry a child
proposing I'm merely not allowing this
person to kill a child but that has a
consequence you're proposing to yeah
we're still woman no one else I carry it
out the forceable act was rape now
there's a life which we both agreed it
would be a secondary forcible act to
kill that life and through that act I
think that's where we disagree so we
might disagree yeah but I don't think it
changes the nature of that act right
you're still killing a life and you're
still forcing a woman to have a baby no
I'm not yeah
no only one of us is taking a proactive
decision there's already a life there's
already a baby okay
I'm merely saying you can't just as eke
if we agreed to life and you did in
every other instance right this is about
the intellectual consistency
you can't kill a life period you can't
kill a life if it's white if it's black
you can't kill life if it's inside the
womb if it's outside the womb you can't
kill a life if it's stray if it's
straight if it's gay if it's it's if
it's trans you can't just kill someone
up that's that's a vital you can't take
someone else's life regardless of how
they came to be that doesn't change the
essence of personhood which is life rape
doesn't change that it's a heinous act
but I'm not forcing a woman to do
anything I'm merely not answering a
tremendous evil the act of rape with an
even greater act of evil the act of
murder
I partially agree partially disagree I
think this is kinda I ran out of points
and I know I appreciate it but I listen
I do appreciate listen if you are
willing to compromise like I said I'm I
do want to save the millions of lives
that are aborted let me ask you this
then let's talk about kind of abortion
cuz the other lady said nine months this
is this is not a trick question okay so
we're in this pre natal chart where is
it okay in the case of rape because you
said only in a case of rape so where do
we allow the termination of that baby
keep in mind most people only know that
they're pregnant right here
it's a prenatal development chart
medical chart oh you don't have to be
you don't have to be I just wanted it I
just this is just something that's
important no one's working you don't
have to be in thank you thank you I
wanted to leave I would leave thank you
I hope you feel I've been polite I'm not
misunderstanding I just there's a wanted
poster of me up on your campus
apparently I mean I don't know that my
opinion would be an effective one just
cuz I don't okay I'm very bad at science
I'm try to avoid it at all possible so
that's why I proposed in investing money
if it's such a heated topic that gets
the whole country just it just if it's a
conversation the whole country is
willing to participate in and waste
billions of dollars in production just
putting two old men and angry women in
the stands talking about it I feel that
they should also use that money of
production to program like money into
researching this about coming up with a
compromise well the reason I ask is
gonna we talked about Texas 20 where
there's 20 weeks so we both agree at
that point right yes okay so I know you
said you're gonna be voting so remember
when someone says it's a travesty for us
to not be able to abort after 20 weeks
debugging remember that at the ballot
box thank you thank you so much more
stuff Marcelo marsala marsala marsala
thank you so much every savea's Lester I
hope
so nervous don't be sorry at all you
didn't do anything offensive no I
appreciate it oh no I listened I've done
this quite a few times and if you're
okay with abortion up to nine months you
know this the goal is to find common
ground have a conversation no I mean I
have another question outside of that
though okay I just don't I don't say
I'll be fruitful if the goal is to see
where we agree yeah I'm open well I'm
open to having my mind changed but my
mind will not be changed to abortion up
to nine months go ahead you can take it
SID actually take it away sin a bit with
what she was talking about brought up a
good and some other people brought up a
good point that essentially an abortion
quote unquote and nine months is just a
c-section c-section which makes complete
sense because the baby can live on its
own it can actually be a baby rather
than a fetus but my question is what
what what about after the baby is born
yeah because it's because this whole
pro-choice for pro-life argument is the
point of contingency is essentially like
what when a woman has body autonomy you
know no I know what it means
yeah you know yeah I know it means
that's not what discussions about it is
that's exactly what a pro-choice
argument is yeah I know you tell me it
is and I had somebody here tell me that
they were a man and to use different
pronouns reality is reality it's not
body autonomy if it's a nine month old
baby because a fetus is literally a
parasite like it is sucking the life
from a mother yeah every single day like
that's literally what happens that's not
even like not a mother I'm guessing like
are you yeah you know I'm not the one
referring to a baby as a parasite that
seems pretty hard I know I'm not even
joking I'm just not you're not gonna
convince me at all as far as abortion up
to nine months so this I don't
understand how this is fruitful that's
what I'm saying it's not a pair a nine
month old baby is not a parasite
c-section it can live on its own so
you're so now you're does happen there's
something wrong with the mother well the
baby is little a second there so now
you're saying you don't support abortion
up to nine months no I do absolutely
that's what I'm saying at some points
there it's like ants I know it's not a
c-section a c-section is not taking out
to pay congratulation you have a baby
boy smack it's all cries and putting it
through a wood chipper ear case no it's
not it's not and this is why we're not
gonna fight listen we've had very civil
dialogues what you want to do am another
Liz monopolize the microphone you just
said a nine-month-old abortion is a
c-section because it's not when you take
it's a question of Bali Tommy that's one
it's not a question of body autonomy
because you're taking the child out of
the body that is what an abortion is you
take the child out of the body it's not
connect to the mother the baby can
usually live on its own it's an actual
baby but you just said you supported
abortion up to nine months that's
essentially what it is I'm so I'm like
okay let me ask you this really clearly
are you still okay are you still okay
with abortion up to nine months abortion
is taking a baby out of a mother
that's called a delivery no no it's
called a delivery when do you want it
and you're considering it a c-section or
abortion when you don't reach full turn
nine months is in full term okay eight
months seven months my point is you said
you're okay with all of it why are we
having a discussion I'm not I am but
she's come back after and I think other
people would have more fruitful
discussion what about this what about
after the baby is born what is what is
the pro-life stance after the baby is
born well this isn't the conversation
right now the conversation is
no it's not the conversation is about
abortion ok listen let me let me let me
read what do you study
holistic I'm an English name okay you're
an English and I can't oh I know exactly
what gonna happen in about two years
time you're gonna be talking about
afterward whether pro-lifers want to
support the child through better
healthcare through better healthcare
service as a mandate socialized health
care and all of a sudden it comes to
mrs. pro-choice is prono choice when it
comes to totalitarian tax regimes the
right to own guns the right to drive an
SUV because you're manipulating the
microphone so I appreciate it no and
that is my microphone that's my
microphone that's my microphone go ahead
you came how you said you the important
to report you have to consider the
holistic issues this is what she's
talking about ending at nine months I
don't agree to deliver the baby yeah
right a time right a time I appreciate
it
thank you thank you so much to everyone
who was respectful had a conversation
sorry maybe we'll be back for sure
here at SMU I'll go get a job I'll
consider it
hey did you enjoy this video here's the
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of the so we don't care cuz you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright